In today's video,
we are taking a look
at the carbonation process,
how it works,
and finding out just what and
what shouldn't be turned
into a fizzy treat.
[Music]
Guys, you have seen both Grant
and Nate make different sorts
of carbonated treats
over the years.
You've seen Nate make
carbonated fruits for summer.
And you've seen Grant make
carbonated ice cream.
So today, I want to take that,
push that limit, and see
what can be carbonated.
Here's the basic idea.
We are taking a variety
of snacks to find out what can
and cannot be carbonated,
and whether or not you should.
To start out with,
we're going to go
with some tried and true things.
We're actually going to try
a cucumber and a bell pepper.
Those are things that I'm
pretty sure can be carbonated
because they are
a little bit more porous.
They hold a lot
of water in them.
They should work,
but the question here is,
do we want them to?
All right, to start out
with we have got a cucumber
and a bell pepper.
Technically, anything
that is porous or liquid
should be able to absorb
the carbon dioxide from dry ice
in a sealed container.
Now, this isn't going
to be airtight
because that wouldn't be safe,
but it should still work.
So that's why I'm going with
a cucumber and a bell pepper.
These both have a very
high water content,
and are technically
a porous sort of flesh.
So the carbon dioxide
should absorb very nicely.
[Music]
All right.
To make fruits,
vegetables, and literally
anything else carbonated,
it's a very simple process.
All you really need is
your carbonated snack
of choice, a cooler,
and some dry ice.
We're going to take our cooler,
and put a decent amount
of dry ice at the bottom.
[Music]
All right.
So we've got a lot
of dry ice in there.
Now, I want to put my cucumber
and my bell pepper in there
with the dry ice to kind of
absorb that carbon dioxide.
Here's the problem.
I don't want them to freeze,
so we have to make sure they're
elevated above the dry ice
so they don't have
contact with it.
Easiest way to do that,
I'm gonna put my slices
into a bowl.
I'm going to elevate them
on top of a paper cup.
And now, for the
really fun part,
we're actually going to seal it
with some cling wrap.
Now, normally,
you do not seal anything
with dry ice inside of it.
But even with cling
wrap on a cooler,
it's not actually
going to be airtight.
Some of that air still going
to escape to the carbon dioxide
isn't going to have
a chance to build up,
and make it to pressurized.
All it's going
to do is make sure
that pressure is more
or less staying internal
without being dangerous.
Perfect.
Let that sit for about an hour.
We should have a fizzy cucumber
and bell pepper.
Now, while we are waiting for
our bell pepper and our cucumber
to hopefully get fizzy,
I want to try
something else, Jell-O.
It is possible to
make a fizzy Jell-O
if you mix it
with a seltzer water
when you're preparing it.
However, I've noticed that a lot
of the bubbles died out.
So I want to see
if mixing it with dry ice
in the cooling process
will actually carbonate it
as we go.
[Music]
Let's put this into a container
that will hopefully,
contain it a little better?
All right, now normally,
you can add ice water to your
Jell-O to help it set faster,
or just pop in the fridge
for a few hours.
I'm just going to add dry ice
until it cools.
Okay, I have dry
ice Jell-O.
[Music]
Okay, so I got impatient
with the Jell-O.
So I'm going to leave
it over there,
let it do its thing,
and we're going to try
something even weirder.
Guys, I want to know
if you can carbonate steak.
Now, the reason
that I'm using steak instead of
any other meat like chicken is
because steak tends to be
a little bit more airy,
I guess you could say.
It's very porous
so I'm hoping
that that means
that the carbon dioxide is going
to sink in a little bit easier.
Whereas if we used
a cooked chicken breast,
it's a lot denser,
and I'm not sure if carbon
dioxide could get through that.
All right.
So I've left this steak
decently rare in the middle.
I'm hoping that'll make
it a little bit easier
to absorb that CO2.
So I'm going to cut
some really thin slices,
and I'm going to throw it
in the cooler right
beside our veggies.
Let's see how our cucumber
and our bell pepper turned out.
[Music]
Oh, did they just
fall off of the cup
when I moved them?
I can't tell if they're going
to need more time.
Let's see.
[Music]
They do not need more time.
That is bizarre.
That was a fizzy bell pepper.
It's not bad.
It's just very strange.
Now, I have had carbonated
watermelon before.
Cucumber tastes similar to me.
[Music]
Now, that's also really weird.
But awesome.
Okay.
Carbonated vegetables.
I'm actually a fan,
that's kind of cool.
All right, I'm going
to toss these back
in here with the steak.
I want to see if we
can get these even fizzier,
and see if the steak
is going to work.
I want to add as much dry ice as
possible without freezing
the bottom of my bowls.
Just the tiniest bit
of water to help
it sublimate a little faster.
All right, I've cut
these little strips
of steak very thin,
in hopes of making this work.
Then close it back up,
seal it with Saran wrap again.
Leave it for about an hour.
All right, here's a sign that we
know that it's working already.
Now, this isn't just
regular cling wrap.
This is Press'n Seal,
and it's still being puffed
up by the carbon dioxide,
which is perfect,
because it is escaping.
This isn't airtight
so it's not dangerous,
but it is definitely
building up some pressure.
So what that means is
we're basically forcing
the carbon dioxide
into the flesh of the meat,
and into the flesh
of our fruit and vegetable.
We have a cucumber,
a bell pepper,
and a piece of steak
being carbonated.
Our Jell-O is still going.
Let's make some ice cream.
We're going to be using
Grant's recipe on how to make
carbonated ice cream today.
I want to try it for myself.
That's going to be
2 cups of Half & Half,
half a cup of powdered sugar,
and a teaspoon
of vanilla extract.
[Music]
Yeah. It's gonna be very
sweet ice cream.
[Music]
All right.
Now, we just add dry ice,
and stir until it freezes.
[Music]
I may have added
too much dry ice.
But you know what?
This is looking awesome.
So if you decide
to make this at home,
just like Grant told you
in the previous video,
make sure you don't swallow any
of these pieces of dry ice.
That would not be good for you.
But the ice cream on its own
should be carbonated now.
[Music]
That's fun.
That is really cool.
I'm going to try and drop it
into some water, and see
if we can actually
see that carbonation
as it dissolves.
Oh, you totally can.
Just a little around the edges.
We had some bubbles rising
to the surface there.
[Music]
Little bit.
You can see some
of that CO2 rising
to the surface just
around the edges.
Our Jell-O is mostly solidified.
But look at how many bubbles
are captured right underneath.
Now, I've seen bubbles rise
to the surface in Jell-O,
and stay there
as it solidifies,
but these are massive bubbles.
I've never seen that before.
[Music]
Okay, that just
dissolved in my mouth.
You know, it's just
like jello cotton candy,
but a little bit fizzy.
That's really cool.
I am concerned
because that didn't have as
much fizz as I wanted it to,
but that's just the bubble.
So let's get down
to the Jell-O itself.
And you can see our jello wasn't
completely set up in the middle,
just try around the edge here.
But look at those bubbles.
These aren't bubbles anymore.
These are just divots
in the surface of the jello.
Moment of Truth.
[Music]
That's my favorite.
Guys, you can make
carbonated Jell-O just
by adding dry ice to it.
That is really really fun.
That is easy to do,
and that tastes so good.
That's fun.
All right, guys,
it's been a few minutes.
And I have Josh with me.
Josh, you ready to try
whatever I put in this cooler?
Not really.
You're gonna.
If you had to guess
for something that I
may have tried to carbonate,
what do you think it might be?
I don't--
I mean, I don't really know
what you've got going on here.
That's right, it's steak.
Oh, sure.
Of course.
That was my second guess.
Yeahm, of course.
Of course, it was.
All right.
I'll try it first.
How is that?
Okay.
[Music]
Go on.
Not only is it carbonated.
It's cold, I assume.
[Music]
That's weird.
Fizzy steak.
That's really weird.
But we made it happen.
Here, I'll try one of these.
Are these--
That's a bell pepper.
Oh, that's fuzzy as well.
[Music]
That's weird.
All right, so I think
out of all these,
the cucumber is actually
got the most carbonated.
They have the
highest water content.
They're very porous.
It was easy
for the carbonation
to sink into them.
So let's see.
[Music]
Yep.
That's like fruit pop rocks.
That feels really weird.
That's cool though.
I'm getting a full meal here.
Can you carbonate
most ordinary food?
Well, if they have
a high water content,
yes, you can.
Should you?
Josh, should you?
No.
But you can,
and it's easy to do.
You can do this at home.
All you need is a cooler,
some dry icem
and some cling wrap.
Just make sure
that your food never touches
the dry ice itself,
and you're good to go.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
This box up here at the top will
take you to our latest video,
and that box of the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit this bomb to
subscribe to the club,
so you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.